perfect si les mains le festival de
venise 20 films en compétition pour le
lion d'or
le premier est français raja de jacques
doillon l'histoire d'un riche occidental
qui séduit une jeune marocaine marie-jo
juin patrick voix nachat à 20 ans elle
découvre le monde
la vie n'a pas été rose l'orphelinat et
la précarité dans la médina de marrakech
et puis le film de jacques doillon dont
elle est la biotech qui l'a fait
basculer dans un conte de fées la jatte
comme radja son personnage ressemble à
un diamant brut
radja engagé à marrakech par as
mentionné qu'ils sentimentalement ne
vaut plus grand-chose de solitude mais
aussi deux mondes qui s'affrontent celui
de la misère et celui de larchamp une
histoire à laquelle nadjaf donne un
éclat singulier à la fois un charme une
drôlerie
je pense aux lumières voilà une lumière
très grande avec derrière tout de suite
là au dessus à côté une gravité terrible
si non vous allez papa tu n'es matelas
elle est aussi très rebelle dans la vie
le titre du film est assez juste parce
qu'elle a la rage
donc raja est assez je sais pas si
jacques doillon l'a fait exprès mais ça
lui convient bien au canada
et aujourd'hui la vie des nachat prend
la couleur de l'espoir
n'imaginez pas un jour venir en europe
dit que les gens puissent me respecter
pour que très rarement il notamment
quant au public de la mostra il ne
pourra être que séduit par la radja de
jacques doillon